yo te ha dejado un rastro de destrucción
sin precedentes en nicaragua y poco se
sabe realmente del poder destructivo que
tuvo en la zona de impacto
específicamente en el caribe del país lo
que sí conocemos es que en zonas como el
norte y el sur ha dejado ciudades
completas incomunicadas debido a la
crecida de ríos también a la caída de
árboles y al daño a la infraestructura
vial
el huracán ha bajado a tormenta tropical
y se dirige actualmente hacia honduras
pero antes ha afectado a unas 100.000
personas con los servicios eléctricos
según el gobierno actualmente hay unas
48 mil personas refugiadas en casi 600
albergues y no reportan la pérdida de
vidas humanas pese a que si hay reportes
extraoficiales de dos menores de edad
que fallecieron debido a la crecida de
un río
y yo está degradado a categoría 1 sigue
siendo mortalmente peligroso según han
advertido a las autoridades del centro
de estudios atmosféricos oceanográficos
y sísmicos en honduras de hecho las
primeras lluvias ya provocaron
devastación en el sector de la mosquitia
y otras ciudades en el norte del país
que ya habían sido afectados previamente
por el paso de la tormenta tropical está
aquí en tegucigalpa la capital se espera
que para las próximas horas las lluvias
se siguen intensificando por lo que las
autoridades ya han hecho la evacuación
de varias familias que como ellas por
ejemplo viven en zonas de riesgo a
orillas de quebradas a orillas de ríos
que atraviesan la capital y en zonas que
normalmente se dan deslizamientos por
eso el llamado de las autoridades a la
población es vehemente abandonen de
inmediato las zonas de alto riesgo
porque hay que tratar de preservar la
vida
el presidente colombiano iván duque se
desplazó a san andrés el principal
archipiélago de la zona y después
sobrevoló providencia donde viven unas
5000 personas y pudo comprobar que hay
un 98 por ciento de la infraestructura
destrozada muchas personas todavía no
han localizado a sus familiares que
habitan en la isla tras el paso del
huracán más fuerte que ha vivido el país
nunca además de las islas caribeñas yo
te ha afectado otras zonas del país como
las regiones de antioquia o el choco así
como ciudades históricas como cartagena
colombia trata de recuperar la
normalidad sin embargo todavía no hay un
balance final de fallecidos
desaparecidos y daños en las
infraestructuras